the goal of canada's energy industry is
pretty straightforward every incremental
barrel that makes its way onto the
market
has a canadian flag stamped on that
crescent point energy ceo craig brixa
says the situation in europe highlights
the importance of energy security and
how canada can play an important role in
securing supply we see the opportunity
we're here to help we're looking forward
to working collaboratively with the
government as we move forward as he
makes these comments the biden
administration says it is working to
secure more energy using a six month one
million barrel per day surge from
strategic reserves to buy some time we
knew there needed to be kind of a gap
filled for that period of time where
expectation and hope is that there could
be greater production by the oil
companies over that course of time
according to a report in the wall street
journal one of the places the
administration would like to get more
production from is canada the only catch
according to the report is keystone xl
is not back on the table energy analyst
richard mason says there's really only
one option left we're down to what can
we do with rail in the near term if we
have enough production to actually get
some more down to the us alberta has
seen a ramp up in rail capacity in
recent years although it isn't the most
economical option and will only add a
couple hundred thousand barrels per day
in capacity i think within five years
something like keystone is going to have
to come heather egzner perot from the
mcdonald laurier institute says years of
underinvestment in energy has put the
world in this tight supply situation and
if the world is serious about energy
security it cannot ignore canadian
capacity we will need more oil canada is
an obvious provider of more oil given
global circumstances
how we get it to market will have to be
resolved in the next few years
and canadian energy leaders are going to
continue to push politicians to make
this happen that opportunity is right in
front of us
tom vernon global news